welcome back to new rockstars as we inch
closer and closer to the multiverse of
madness are we about to learn that all
of this craziness is due to the actions
of one powerful woman and i'm not
talking about our beloved scarlet witch
who has never done anything wrong in her
life i don't want to hear it i didn't
want to hear it it was an accident i'm
talking about everyone's favorite badass
loki variant by the name of sylvie is
this what he who remains was warning us
about well this is rogue theory the show
where we pitched the wildest theories
for the nerdy titles that we love my
name is mt and growing world with me
today is twitch variant that will break
open any multiverse it's angelica trey
what's going on angelico hey i really
like that intro i feel so cool right now
it's cause you are cool angelico well
thank you live in it oh my gosh it's who
you are
and someone who's always ready to
deviate from he who remains a script
it's whitney van landingham what's going
on girl a man always willing to deviate
[Music]
that sounds so dirty
[Laughter]
and finally someone who always knocks
twice on the time door it's offspring
producer brandon what's going on hello
hello i'm the i'm the jessica clemens
variant today from a different video you
are
slipping in you know i think that that
means that you should be long hair
brandon then in that oh no no
you gotta pay extra uh on my my only
fans to see the long hair you gotta okay
we got a sub jar only fantastic
to get that get this started sorry guys
daddy's gotta make money okay
you gotta teach me your secret because
uh the crops ain't growing that's not
working we've learned a lot this week
the importance of the loki series as a
lead-in to the events of the upcoming
doctor strange sequel which makes us
think that the popular series prompted
some script changes but just how
important are the events of loki which
leads us to our first topic of today did
loki give us the illuminati that we see
in the doctor strange 2 trailer because
in an interview this week a producer on
doctor strange of the multiverse of
madness described how the introduction
of variants in the loki series changed
the direction of the film and they even
brought in loki head writer michael
waldron to work on the script for the
doctor strange sequel so does this mean
that there was no illuminati before the
death of he who remains and was the
upcoming film going to look completely
different and how do we think this
expansion of the concept of variance in
the multiverse will play out as the film
dives deeper into the whole concept so i
definitely think loki is a huge
pivotal point in the mcu and i i think
that
i think that the fall of he who remains
is not
what triggered the start of the
illuminati but i think that multiverse
of madness
there's going to be a lot going on here
and i think that sylvie is going to be
behind it but strange will also be a
part of it somewhere in there
because we've already seen some
characters like i don't know i mean back
of the head
features with like professor x and
we've got some other introductions
coming into the mcu that have in the
comics been part of the illuminati so i
definitely think that it's something
that's a huge trigger from the loki
series but will come to fruition during
multiverse of madness yeah i like the
idea that there was you know they they
were working on doctor strange too
putting together a script and then they
see loki and we know that there was
reshoots and every marvel movie has
reshoots and then like a second random
reshoots like they they bake it into the
original schedule but i bet when they
saw dr or when they saw loki and this
concept of variance they were like oh
okay this is very interesting like i'm
totally convinced that the script didn't
include the illuminati until after they
saw loki and they're like oh we could
have this whole thing come in uh because
that interview you talk about mt they
they do mention like oh because they did
all this work on loki we don't have to
like explain everything all over again
right and even all
all of popular culture is getting into
this concept of multiverses you know the
dc is going to have the flash movie
which is going to do the same thing and
so it's like society is primed to
understand the multiverse now and they
have no way home and it's like they kind
of get it right like they get that like
oh there's these different versions of
things out that exist out there but now
i think with like doctor strange like
great we can start in the middle like
people get it to put it all together
like sylvie killing he who remains means
we get like the illuminati now and i
think they probably existed and they
weren't able to get into our universe
because of what he who remains was doing
now that he's dead they're going to bust
in they're going to be like what have
you guys been doing here we've been
trying to help we can't get the [ __ ]
if the door was locked and now we can
get in this thing that's what you guys
doing you know what i if i was professor
rex i'd be the same way oh totally i
could definitely see sylvie taking
matters into her own hands too and
initiating the illuminati because it
really seems like there's there's gonna
be she's gonna try to
gain control where she can
especially probably after dealing with
the guilt of he who remains downfall um
so we'll see what happens there but
silvia's going to play a huge role in
this wait so do you think that sylvie
like could actually be like the head
honcho behind the formation of the
illuminati i i think that she could
definitely be maybe the main
like the person that
pitches the idea so i don't know if
she'll be like the top dog in it but you
know maybe plant some seeds you know how
sneaky silvia is like a nick fury
she will sneak if professor x is like
it's time we we should tell them the
truth the truth is we do whatever this
lady tells us to do uh
she's got a big knife and we're freaked
out guys i think sylvia's going around
disseminating information yeah and she's
she's like
starting up a lot of these ideas and
like planting a lot of these seeds and
then of course we're going to pull in
you know it's going to be a big main
thing because now they need an
organization to come through and
actually handle stuff like the
illuminati
um beforehand
before any of this havoc is brought
right and so we'll probably bring in
like neymar eventually and and obviously
professor x and
some other folks you know and i think
that it's gonna be
really fun and really cool and maybe
we'll get you know stephen
well i i'm excited for that i was like
kind of like the shadowy kind of
sketchy
you know organizations or the
like okay
well because here's the thing it's like
it's hard to be a hero or call yourself
a hero and then also be like operating
around rules or before like trying to
prevent something so i really like the
concept of the illuminati so i'm gonna
run fully in that direction oh yeah i
think that having an illuminati
introduced in doctor strange too and
especially in a doctor strange series
like you said it makes so much sense
considering that the illuminati sort of
did what
a lot what dr strange was doing like
they break the rules and like they sort
of do things you're like you know what
we know better so like we're just going
to do things in secret so like they're
sort of like a parallel to doctor
strange in a way but what you got
whitney
well
uh there was a clip where little sweet
baby tony stark is on his phone and you
can see that he has an illuminati app on
his oh yeah yeah oh my god so i think
that the illuminati has been around and
i think that they have kind of been
preparing behind the scenes
for something like this to happen
but something of this magnitude has not
happened yet so we haven't
seen them yet because like even thanos
that was more of messing with our
universe but he wasn't messing with
other multiverses so i think that at
that point in time they probably were
formed but they didn't have any reason
to meet re thanos
and now that shit's getting [ __ ] up in
the multiverse now they have a reason to
come together on screen
sadly r.i.p iron man but i think that
obviously professor x is happening but
um
like in the original illuminati lineup
doctor strange was a part of it so i
think that the dark doctor strange that
we saw in the multiverse of madness
trailer could be the representative of
the illuminati and they're catching our
stephen up to speed when they're like
let's tell them the truth actually
here's your variant we're all part of
the illuminati and guess what we're in
charge of making sure that wanda doesn't
[ __ ] up the multiverse i love the idea
of tony stark like constantly messaging
the illuminati throughout the events of
like the mcu and them just being like
it's not a big deal it's like there's
this guy he made an arc reactor he's got
whips and he's trying to kill me and
they're like ah that's very small
potatoes yeah very small potatoes that
has nothing to do with like literally
breaking reality so until reality breaks
don't call us yeah yeah thanos is here
he's got all these stones and like half
the people are gone in the universe and
they're like man that's real i know it
seems bad this is not a big
[Laughter]
deal just your universe
what are you gonna do
it's really really affecting you guys
you're like we killed our thanos what's
your problem like what's that
you couldn't kill your thanos that
sounds like a you problem
he's like peter parker no i was
spider-man yeah just sending messages
yeah he's like hey illuminati uh i did
this cool thing today i stopped whiplash
like oh that's cool that's nice
nice tony
whitney brings up a really good like
idea too or a really good you know
concept around are we going to be
getting variants or multiple variants in
the illuminati and how
is that going to operate you know so are
we going to get like
i don't know captain carter and and some
other folks involved it would be cool to
see like captain carter on the
illuminati because i i don't think
they're gonna like one for one the
comics right i don't think they're gonna
bring in black bolt that seems like so
insane and they would have to kind of
acknowledge in humans which they kind of
want everyone to forget about in humans
yeah
they don't
i think that if they do introduce black
bolts i i i would be honestly super
shocked if they even brought back ants
and mount at all because like even if
they did a variant of ants and mounts
black bolts people just be like what is
this
i didn't watch in humans yeah i don't
know the significance of that so they
can just recast them completely
but i just feel like the inhumans just
haven't really done well in the comics
and in live action even though i
personally love the inhumans and marvel
should totally make it in humans anime
right i don't know why they haven't done
that yet sorry i'm just very passionate
about this one specific thing
demanding in humans anime
tell us how you feel dope like that's oh
man that is my true feelings i mean i
would love like a world where you have
to pit the the mutants against the
inhumans in in the mcu and it's like
only one can remain who's it gonna be yo
like there is a whole arc in the comics
of just that the right whole war between
the humans and the x-men i would love to
see that on screen personally but like i
just feel like a till in society the
whole in human society with how their
whole caste system set up people aren't
really down with that it's just not
really great they're not a great royal
family
so yeah angelica what you're saying
about like aren't there multiple
illuminati's or is there just like one
illuminati you know are there other
professor x's like why don't i get to be
on the illuminati i'm a good i'm a good
professor x
that's what you're saying
let me be on the let me yeah i'm good
yeah there could be another tony already
on it right and like our tony really
wanted to be on he's like look guys i
made an app i put it on my phone please
let me in they're like you gotta get to
me yes i decided
for you will you please let me join the
team now
we gotta we gotta we have a tony you're
a great tony we got it okay
yeah how surprised would you be if tony
actually could communicate across like
the multiverse on an app like the
illuminati app it's just like the
whatsapp but for the multiverse yeah so
you can communicate with your variants
in other galaxies
i would do that a lot actually that's
like when i have to like text my cousins
in england on the whatsapp group chat
you know yeah it would be exactly like
that except
yeah i'd be trying to find out if i'm
like still short in all my variants i'd
be like are you are you five foot one
still how tall are you
yeah what if there's actually like tall
variants of angelica and whitney out
there whatever like really tall very nba
angelica
that would be amazing who knows anything
about sports i love that i love that for
her i also love the idea of our tony
stark constantly sending pictures to
like the illuminati app and it downloads
on their local things and they're like
tony keeps filling up my phone because
my phone automatically
downloads illuminati pictures
and they're just zombies because his
beard looked like really good that day
they're just pictures of him and peter
parker because he's sad he's like i miss
my son
oh
that is
peter parker yeah that's all right
tony begging the illuminati for help
because he lost his peter parker and
they're all like
that's like really not our thing dude
again that's your peter your problem we
don't do that that's your thing you're
peter your problem that sounds wrong
that's exactly right angela is exactly
right look at the sign
don't make me not decide your problem
don't make me tap the sign no these are
all amazing theories and for that i'm
awarding everybody 10
million rogue dollars
you can exchange those points at your
local walmart just kidding they're not
real but yes everyone gets 10 million
points because you guys are so smart i
love you guys a lot but up next we're
going to talk about one of spider-man's
oldest villains but first epic hero shop
has released their new line of merch
inspired by the batman and it's super
cool they've got three different shirts
some socks and even a riddler inspired
tie a mysterious die i would recommend
wearing it to a job interview maybe
unless you're you know interviewing to
become a criminal mastermind and i also
heard a rumor that they're about to
release a new limited edition latest
obsession shirt design so keep an eye
out for that over at the new rockstars
newrockstarsmerch.com website it also
it's discouraging if you're only making
a small dent on your multiple credit
card balances each month because you're
only paying the minimums upstart can
help you pay off your existing debt
quickly and start finally getting ahead
in your finances so whether it's paying
off credit cards consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses over a million people have used
upsart to get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date so rather than
looking at your credit score alone
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income employment and other
information provided in your loan
application to find you a smarter rate
for your loan you can check your rate
without impacting your credit score in
just five minutes for loans between one
thousand and get this 50 000
that is a lot of money and you can even
receive your funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan i
did this personally like i actually did
this and it's actually very very fast so
i can personally vouch for this um so
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
rogue theory that's upstart.com rogue
theory and do not forget to use our url
to let them know that we sent you
because that helps us a lot lot of parts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other informations
provided in your loan application so go
to upstart.com
rogue theory and hey we all got our
goals for the year like starting a
real-life illuminati or reading the
darkhold cover to cover but at the top
of a lot of people's lists is learning a
new language with babel the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions around the new
rockstar's office we got staffers
learning spanish and french using babel
and they love how addictively fun babble
makes learning a new language the
process is fast and easy and transfers
well to real world use babel's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go babel's lessons
were created by over 100 language
experts and their teaching method has
been scientifically proven to be
effective and with babel you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german plus
babel's speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent there are so many ways to learn
with babble and in addition to lessons
you can access podcast games videos
stories and even live classes and plus
it comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee so start your new language
learning journey today with babel and
right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months if you know how to do
math for the price of three just go to
babel.com and use promo code rogue that
is
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com code rogue babel
language for life when i've got my
stance socks on i always know that my
feet are both comfortable and stylish
and now they're taking that comfort and
style from toe to head with the launch
of their new active apparel line stance
has a super soft line of sweatpants and
joggers shirts hoodies and more that
look as good as they feel and they're
available in a full range of fits prints
and fabrics i think the coolest parts of
stance apparel is all of their
collaborations with artists and
intellectual properties and wear their
nightmare before christmas hoodie over
their bob marley t-shirt with incredible
hulk socks and let the world know all
the stuff that you're into at the same
time because why not it's just efficient
and stan's philosophy is that you should
never have to sacrifice your own
individual style for the sake of comfort
and now you don't have to so whether
you're relaxing around the house working
out at the gym or just running all over
town stance now delivers signature
softness and creativity and a full line
of active apparel lines from toe to head
stance has got you covered so head on
over to stance.com and get 15 off your
first purchase use promo code rogue at
checkout to apply and enjoy the color
and comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance stitched different now we haven't
heard too much about the sony
spider-verse film craven the hunter
which is currently in development but we
did get some exciting casting news this
week fred heshinger has just been cast
as the chameleon in the upcoming craven
the hunter from the pages of the amazing
spider-man number one way back from the
year 1963 which is just feels like
yesterday comes dimitri schmurdikov aka
the chameleon um he was spider-man's
first super villain and now he's getting
his first ever live-action appearance so
how will a second major villain affect
the plot of this edition of the sony
spider-verse well i think like including
the chameleon is very interesting right
in the comics they establish he's the
half-brother of craven the hunter right
uh and they also did something cast um
what's his name he loves to fight
everybody from australia uh uh
russell crowe russell crowe
kangaroo jack was recently cast as
craven i would love kangaroo jacket
yeah they cast russell crowe in this
movie too right as he he's going to be
maybe another member of craven's family
so it's looking like a family affair
right how all the families are coming
together
um
i i think i think it's cool to have
chameleon you know as like spider-man's
like og
villain super villain
first super villain he faced he's the
reason everyone in new york hates
spider-man because he dressed up as
spider-man and went around and committed
a bunch of crimes when spider-man was
trying to join the fantastic four
because he needed the money uh and then
everyone so no one trusts spider-man
because of these initial events where
they're like i thought spider-man was a
bad guy didn't he was like no that was
another guy um so i think they might use
chameleon and it would be really cool if
we see spider-man and craven the hunter
and it just turns out to be like
chameleon right like pretending
they keep teasing spider-man in like the
sony venomverse so that would be super
interesting i do like that idea of like
you know
this this craving the hunter chasing the
wrong man just like oh this is an
annoying guy who just wants to be
spider-man it's not his half-brother
constantly getting in the way and like
you know chameleon is an animal and like
craving the hunter likes to hunt animal
true things so like maybe he's hunting
chameleon in this movie like maybe
that's the person he's hunting he's like
where is this chameleon so i do like
that idea i mean it's it's wild right
now because it really feels like sony's
just taking it all the way back we're
currently in a golden era of
spider-verse right now and we're just
building it up we've got
the very first super villain for
spider-man now
confirmed and
i think that
for how late this feels like it was
announced even though you know it's
what's craven's coming out january next
year or something the way that they
announced this i feel like they're
building up for more maybe later down
the road so we have chameleon and he's
probably gonna be popping in
throughout craven the hunter but maybe
there's going to be
more of
him down the line
is
what i picked up from this but i think
it's really cool that sony is building
out this
even more extended spider verse right
now well it seems like sony wants to get
to that sinister six at some point right
with them focusing on these like
villains constantly and like oh yeah
maybe even before we see another
spider-man in the sony verse they're
gonna do
six villains who have no one to fight i
don't know
yeah
[Laughter]
i mean yeah there have been plans to to
make a sinister six movie for sure for
the longest time i mean ever since the
end of the amazing spider-man 2 where
they teed this sinister six and that
never actually happened um so yeah i
think they're they're starting to build
some type of sinister stick scenario
with your cravings and with your
chameleons and like i'm just wondering
how that's gonna factor in to like the
whole spider-verse narrative like are we
gonna see them in like in the mcu either
to cross over to like you know bother
our peter parker like in like you know i
have this weird idea like this is sort
of random but like do you think that
jameson is going to be involved with the
chameleon in any way because we know
that jameson was involved with the
creation of the scorpion and we know
that scorpion is an element um in in the
no way home trilogy i think that what if
like what if
jay john jameson creates the the
chameleon along with
the
um scorpion that makes sense because
like if jameson brings in chameleon
and he's like i need you to dress up
like spider-man and go commit some crime
so i can get some news stories right he
could be doing it
exactly
like i think that he just really wants
to defame spider-man because he just
doesn't like him he's just this weird
like neurosis against spider-man he's
just like i don't care what pictures i
get of spider-man as long as i see him
doing crimes so chameleon just do crimes
to draw him out um silly yeah great
impression listen i could i you know i
could be devil's advocate for
i could be devil's advocate for jay
jonah jameson here he's got a point like
we don't need someone in a costume
operating outside the bounds of the law
who's beholden to nobody who does
whatever he wants who causes damage uh
and we turn out it turns out it's a kid
and like that's not cool either okay
we've been webbing everywhere which yes
it disintegrates at some point but we
don't know the long-term health effects
of this webbing in the city like what is
it oh you sound like they're coming out
i'm just saying i'm i'm i'm
i'm advocating on behalf of jameson here
because he's being badmouthed and he's
not able to respond right now okay
someone has got to regulate these
superheroes they got to be stopped you
know what maybe i've been converted i
don't know what's happening to me
[Laughter]
damn you've been listening to too much
about the jay jonah jameson podcast no i
can't i can't put down the data too much
spider-man
that's been getting into your brain all
right listen the podcast is great and
all the supplements they sell me have
been really helping uh really helping my
oh my god oh no
my marriage hasn't improved dramatically
i'm on those nootropics man my mind has
never worked better okay
what if
chameleon takes advantage of the
multiversal
cracks from no way home
and he uses that to get into the andrew
garfield universe and he pretends to be
gwen stacy come back to live
variant
just to trap andrew garfield and break
his heart all over again i know that
that's funny he just wants to break his
heart that's all i want to say but
america wants to see this man sad oh my
god that's what america wants he plays
that we want this man to be happy and in
love and i think that the chameleon
could just swoop on in and break his
beautiful little heart all over it
we should get neve from catfish involved
yes
yes yes it's just an episode of catfish
but it's spider-man the amazing
spider-man 3.
why does this chameleon clan sound more
evil than just like i don't know
destroying the world
do we think like chameleon is gonna be
like the real bad guy in this movie
because like all these movies right
they're about the villains you know
venom and morbius and now this one and
it's like they're the villains but
there's always a a more villainy villain
there right and they stop them they're
ostensibly the protagonists they're the
good person so it's like is this one
gonna be again like trying to make us
empathize with craven or will craven
always be the bad guy are they gonna let
a villain be a villain let cruella kill
the dogs that's what i'm saying that's
awesome
okay
like cruella killed the dog i want to
see it i want to see her kill a puppy
okay i honestly think that you're on the
right track there brandon because i
think that in order for these movies
like you know venom and your cravens to
be successful you've got to have to root
for the central character so i think
that you know the chameleon even though
craven is a psychopath himself the
chameleon will probably be a worse
person you know probably dressing up as
your as your girlfriend and making you
make out with
like i love the idea that the community
is changing his face he just like puts a
wig on and like andrew garfield buys it
bamboozled again
what you're doing how this is possible
oh yeah i'm my bad guys
i got spider bite i don't know why and
your andrew garfield's just that like
desperate for ready stacy then when he
finds out that's when he turns dark so
that that was the whole dark period the
og chameleon from the beginning of the
comics like he just like used makeup and
like special effects kind of like yeah
he was just
yeah he was like a good actor and he
would put on makeup and stuff so i love
the idea of dressing up as gwen stacy
put on lipstick all sloppily then he got
like he got a belt buckle
that sprayed a gas that made his like
face malleable so he would like he'd
like spray his face with his belt buckle
which
must look insane if you see this guy on
the bus like yeah the 60s were a wild
time bro and then like mushing his face
around and be like i'm gwen stacy
you just have to say the name over and
over again honestly i i think i've
witnessed worse things on the bus so
yeah that's true
and you become a different person it's
harrowing every bus ride is heroin in
its own way yeah
for sure same for him what do you guys
think of the idea of the chameleon being
part of team mysterio because we know
that team mysterio is still out there so
like what if there's like a variant
version of team mysterio in this
separate universe
with raven where like they're just like
we don't have a quentin back we don't
have like uh the barf technology but we
kind of want to be like mess up
spider-man anyway or like just be bad
anyway through the chameleon like we're
just gonna
be the chameleon instead of mysterio so
i love the idea that the mcu is just
like taylor swift and is still not over
jake gyllenhaal so we gotta keep making
we gotta keep including him even if he's
been dead for like the past three movies
mysterio's gotta stay in the forefront
we gotta keep making mysterio content
you guys
jake gyllenhaal's legacy must stay in
town i mean at all times i just i just
want a scene with a chameleon like in
mrs doubtfire when he's at a restaurant
the comedian's at a restaurant with like
three different people he's gonna keep
going to the bathroom to change who he
is yeah oh my god like the sony's
spider-verse they're jealous that that
main mcu is doing scrolls right man
they're like man i wish we had scrolls
and they got we got one guy who we got
one scroll he's just gonna go around
changing uh whoever he is right i just
want to see him smash the pie in his
face and do the hello hello
like craven shows up in his apartment
but he's not ready yet and he's like
not ready i gotta i don't have my belt
buckle it's at the shop
i can't change my face okay these are
all amazing theories and for angelica
and brandon i'm going to award you seven
million rogue box oh my gosh so many i
love them so much i love the idea of
chameleon dressing up as spider-man and
like sort of just pretending to be him
and kind of leading craven off the trail
or even just becoming the villain of
that movie outright and craven just
going after him i think it'd be really
fun and i also love the idea of
chameleon just becoming a bigger part of
the mcu list later on and just like just
becoming this mystique type figure and
just like feeling hey you thought it was
your friend but it's actually me
chameleon i would love that just for him
just to be annoying forever that's love
i love it but
i have to give it give really 10 million
rogue points for the idea of tricking
andrew garfield
into thinking that when stacy was still
alive
this is one fire man it's a good theory
mrs squid fire oh my gosh like literally
oh you need this movie to happen 10
million
times my god
incredible this come on marvel studios
you know you better be watching and
listening to this
sony too let us write it let us
seriously
mt right mrs
hello
and now it's time for our rogue question
are you guys ready for this one yeah
yeah yeah all right gang
because in the recently released marvel
assembled on disney plus which
chronicled the behind-the-scenes events
of the hawkeye series confirmed that all
of the avengers were invited to rogers
the musical the premiere in new york
city that and only hawkeye was the only
one that showed up which is kind of
messed up so what are the best excuses
that the other living avengers gave for
not attending because you know tony
stark big time dead so he's got it he's
got to get his tony had a good reason
natalie had a good reason
because everyone knows he would be their
front row just to see you know himself
on stage just because he's got ego like
that the whole cast to go get his his
clothing tailored or something
something after i don't know i'm trying
to think like something like oh i gotta
go get my pants tailored i feel like i'm
thinking of something like a little too
further down the line here because i
just think it's funny how he always has
his pants on still
um
i don't know why it triggers him to
become the hulk is that theater kids
just really piss him off yeah
i could see him just sitting there i
could see bruce banner just sitting
there throughout the entire musical
looking so uncomfortable but with like a
very very awkward smile on his face and
then just like he's just slowly kind of
just trying to keep it down like just
veins bulging i like to think that wanda
maximoff did all of wanda vision just to
avoid going to rogers the musical uh
yeah you know what i'll show you a real
production here's wanda vision
[Laughter]
i'll show you how to do a production
wanda's like my actors are better town
can enjoy yeah yeah wanda's over there
doing like a schenectady over in
westfield she's like making the whole
town put on her play i like to imagine
that he's not an avenger but
scott lang finds out that he's in the
musical like after the premiere and he's
like pissed that he wasn't invited like
his daughter shows them like a video on
tic toc they're like dad you're in this
thing you weren't at the battle new york
he's like what i should have been
invited
this is insane and he probably shows up
like two weeks later and they like don't
let him in or whatever he's like what am
i ant-man
and he's gotta shrink down and then
sneak in to go watch it i would love to
see that oh my god i like to think that
ant-man deliberately committed a crime
uh so that jimmy wu would once again
place him under house arrest so he
didn't have to go that way he could go
see the musical he was just like this
sounds bad i don't want to be a part of
this so he gets arrested and then jimmy
will babysits him he's outside jimmy's
house just like breaking his mailbox
with a baseball bat and he like do it
do it arrest me
amazing you guys are so funny but no i
these are again
amazing answers but i once again got to
give it to whitney for this image of
just having hulk in the audience just
like trying to hold in his anger
exclaiming musicals i hate you kids i
can't do it
i know i'm always angry but i just can't
do it
we didn't break out the song even though
they were drew just like he just [ __ ]
hated whenever they made him play zip
zap zop you know like in high school and
he was just like i cannot be around
these types of people anymore i hate
stairs in theater kids
do it which makes whitney our winner for
today even though again you guys were
all amazing people and i love making
these rogue theories with you and going
rogue every week because you guys are
geniuses geniuses comic book geniuses
but that is it for this episode of rogue
theory i want to thank our very special
guest angelica trey whitney van
lenningham and off-screen producer
brandon support them on twitter go
follow them and wherever whatever
they're doing like especially on twitch
angelica is an amazing twitcher go do
you watch her on twitch and that's
amazing and everybody just follow
everybody else too and follow me on
twitter if you want to see me tweet some
weird stuff at mastertainment and
support our channel by checking out all
of our awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com thank you for
spending time with us and we'll see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you